it's crucial if you're gonna navigate
this journey that you have to do an
adequate amount of internal excavation
to kind of understand yourself like what
is the narrative that you're walking
around with that's dictating your
behaviors and is that true get into your
past traumas and how they're triggering
unhelpful Behavior patterns time and
time again because there's an
unconscious kind of operating system
here that will persist without that kind
of work and so you can read your book
and you can do all these tools but if
you're not actually Reckoning with all
of that you're unlikely to kind of claw
out of whatever Paradigm you're in and
and start you know reorganizing your
life around a better trajectory